since lin-manuel Miranda created the hip
musical Hamilton history has had its
eyes on both him and the young scrappy
and hungry founding father at the center
of its story but just how much of what
you see on screen is Broadway fiction
versus historical fact
yippie Kay we be lovers I'm Jon and in
this video i'm revealing seven
intriguing differences between Miranda's
popular show and the true story of
Alexander Hamilton and I'll be
explaining why these changes were made
in the musical Hamilton and burr first
meet in 1776 the tune Waris happens is
Aaron Burr sir and it kicks off with
Hamilton wanting the lowdown from fellow
orphan burr and how he graduated college
so quickly and it continues with the
pair heading to a tavern where Hamilton
first meets John Lauren's Lafayette and
Hercules Mulligan
however this entire encounter is made up
back in the real world Hamilton had
already started college in 1773 or 74
and had likely finished his studies by
1776 he also already knew Mulligan
before the date in the song as he
boarded with him shortly after arriving
in New York and he didn't meet Lorenz or
Lafayette until later in the decade
but the show's fictional first meeting
between these men as well as its
condensed timeline serve many vital
purposes it allows lin-manuel Miranda to
quickly introduce us to some of the
musicals main characters and show us how
they relate to its star the scene also
clearly sets up the differences between
Hamilton and burr a crucial part of the
show and Miranda's decision for
Hamilton's real friends Lauren's
Lafayette a Mulligan to wrap in a more
simple old-school style sets the stage
to reveal Hamilton's incredible
intellect and sophisticated way with
words that showcased in the densely
packed rhymes of the musicals very next
number my shot Miranda makes what he
calls another historical leap in that
song when Hamilton says he punched a
college versa
apparently the show's historical
consultant Ron chernow whose biography
of Hamilton inspired Miranda to create
the musical launched a bit when he heard
the line as Hamilton wasn't needlessly
violent
however Miranda just couldn't say no to
this fictionalized fight appearing in
the final show as in his words the rhyme
was too good to pass up it's a blur
sorry he handles the financials you
punch the bursary yes much is made in
the musical of the mutual attraction
between Angelica Schuyler and Hamilton
in reality historians disagree just how
intimate their relationship was while
some believe the pair was satisfied with
a close friendship and exchanging
letters through the years others suggest
they were actually lovers still when it
comes to his musical Miranda ignores a
few facts historians are certain about
when Angelica meets Hamilton in the show
were told she has no brothers and that
she's also single so she has to marry
someone rich less she's the one who
introduces her sister Eliza to Hamilton
however a quick look at the history
books proves none of that was true
in fact the elder Schuyler sister wasn't
present when Eliza met her future spouse
and not only had Angelica been married a
number of years by the time she did meet
Hamilton the musical instead shifts
Angelica's marriage forward in time to
the very end of act 1 as for siblings
records showed that Angelica definitely
had several brothers according to
Miranda his brain wanted him to forget
all that while writing because it's
stronger dramatically if she can't marry
the penniless Hamilton because of social
pressures rather than the fact that
she's already wet also Miranda was
trying to make a larger point here that
Angelica is a world-class intellect in a
world that does not allow her to flex it
after Hamilton very publicly reveals his
extramarital affair in the Reynolds
pamphlet The Musical shows his wife
Eliza's reaction in the song burn where
she sets fire to the letters he wrote
her in real life Eliezer never commented
publicly on the affair and historians
don't know for sure when why or how she
destroyed her letters that future
historians or wonder how Eliza reacted
indeed it even seems to be something of
an assumption to say that she did
actually disposed of them herself rather
than say someone else having done it or
them simply having gone missing over the
years but for Miranda the fact
Eliza's response is lost in time not
only gave him enormous freedom to
imagine her actions an outpouring of
emotion in burn but it also added
another layer of drama and humanity to
the overall story a change of
protagonist in the song tendril
Commandments has an important effect on
the musical as a whole the song features
a face-off between soldiers and
statesmen John Lorenz and fellow
military man Charles Lee who is charged
with assaulting George Washington now
while these two men did indeed engage in
combat in 1778 the show departs from
reality by having Aaron Burr act as
Lee's second when in real life leaves
second was actually major evan Edwards
so why did Miranda make this change
well burrs presence in this scene sets
up the show's climactic combats between
him and Hamilton creating a parallel
between these two moments this adds an
irony to his and Hamilton's final fate
because in this first act songbird tells
Hamilton can we agree that duels are
dumb and immature and that it's absurd
that a man should have to answer for his
words against another with his life yes
in the second act song your obedient
servant the tables have turned and now
burr is demanding Hamilton pay for the
disrespect he's shown him just as
Lawrence demanded of Lee in act 1 also
by adding Burr and deleting Edwards from
the action Miranda re-emphasizes the
continual importance of burr throughout
Hamilton's life while also avoiding
having to introduce us to a new minor
character Alexander
so the set of rules for one-on-one
combat known as the code dwell o did
exist at the time the show set a Miranda
drew heavily on historian Joanne
Freeman's book on the subject while
writing however he does take an
interesting little creative Liberty in
this song as in reality there were
actually over 20 rules for Zhu Ling the
song cuts down the real number of rules
as it was directly inspired by the track
ten crack commandments by rapper biggie
smalls whose influence runs throughout
the musical and along with Miranda's
many other musical inspirations bridges
the gap between the Revolutionary era
and modern day for 21st century
audiences oh and of course presenting
just ten rather than 20 plus rules also
helps keep the show moving and the
audience interested by the way the song
itself came about because Miranda wanted
in the first act to introduce the
audience to how Zhu Ling worked so that
when it was time for Hamilton and birds
famous confrontation in the second act
he didn't have to interrupt or slow down
the action with explanations Ron chernow
is biography describes Hamilton as a
committed abolitionist and lin-manuel
Miranda's musical takes a very similar
view of its protagonists revolutionist
in fact right from the opening number
Miranda portrays Hamilton's early life
as being marked by trauma and a
first-hand view of the brutal practices
of the slave trade every day while
slaves were being slaughtered and carted
away across the waves he struggled and
kept his guard up then later he has him
engaged in a rap battle with Thomas
Jefferson where Hamilton derives the
hypocrisy of the future president for
owning slaves and Miranda himself says
it was cathartic to get to express this
to Jefferson every night finally at the
end of the show Eliza sings that
Hamilton would have done more for slaves
had he lived longer
however the show's progressive depiction
of Hamilton on this issue airbrushes out
the more complicated and problematic
reality while the real Hamilton was part
of the New York manumission society and
according to historian Annette
gordon-reed did publicly criticize
Jefferson's racist belief that black
people were inferior
Hamilton's record from the 1790s until
his death in 1804 includes little to no
action against slavery in other words as
Gordon Reid says opposing slavery was
never at the forefront of his agenda and
many historians and political theorists
agree others though maintained Hamilton
was an abolitionist by the standard of
the founding period pointing as proof to
his contrasting views on the subject
with Jefferson but what role did slaves
play in Hamilton's own life well not
only did the real-life Hamilton buy and
sell slaves for his in-laws but some
sources indicate he may have bought them
for himself as well or at least hired
them indeed Hamilton's own mother had
slaves and bequeath them to her sons
upon her death however due to her
children's in legitimacy they didn't
actually inherit them the historian Phil
Magnus is probably accurate to see
Hamilton as a slave beneficiary who had
qualms with the institution however to
call him an abolitionist let alone the
leading abolitionist of his generation
who's an historical absurdity when it
comes to Miranda's musical despite the
fact so many of the founding fathers
were slave owners only Jefferson is
explicitly depicted as such still actor
Christopher Jackson who plays George
Washington found his own way of giving a
subtle nod to the first president slave
ownership in the show and I talk about
that in my video on all the things you
missed in the movie so why does Miranda
portray Hamilton this way well a big
factor must be turnout biography which
highlights Hamilton's progressiveness on
this subject and heavily inspired
Miranda's musical and chair now is
actually the show's historical
consultant as well then there's a fact
that Miranda sees Hamilton as an
inspirational an aspirational figure to
him as well as someone who reminds him
of his own father which as historian
Lyra Montero suggests would also likely
make it more difficult for him to truly
incorporate slavery into the story of
Hamilton's law
another likely reason the show glosses
over the contradictions and Hamilton's
anti-slavery stance is that as Gordon
Reid says it makes him more palatable
and attractive to modern audiences as
chair now has pointed out history is
long messy and complicated and a
Broadway show is short coherent and
tightly constructed and Miranda does
manage to squeeze an incredible amount
of information into the musical and even
includes direct quotes from Hamilton and
some of the other characters own
writings but what does Miranda himself
have to say on this
speaking recently to NPR he noted that
other than calling out Jefferson on his
hypocrisy with regards to slavery
Hamilton doesn't really say much else
over the course of Act two and I think
that's actually pretty honest as he
didn't really do much about it after
that although he voiced anti-slavery
beliefs he remained complicit in the
system well some scholars point out the
ironic tension between the musicals
diverse cast and what they see is an
overly whitewashed script as Kate Keller
notes in the Smithsonian magazine over
the years the show's creators have
highlighted the idea that Hamilton is a
story about America then told by America
now and back in the show's early days of
2015
cast members including Leslie Odom jr.
and Debbie dig spoke about it giving
them a sense of ownership over American
history because they felt it's their
history - for the first time ever during
a much more recent interview writer
Tanja Renee Stidham spoke with the cast
about the timeliness of the film's
release as she put it allowing us an
opportunity to revisit and reckon with
the history of this nation's founding
fathers during a national uprising and
Christopher Jackson added that it
doesn't touch on everything it's not
meant to solve problems it's meant to
inspire thought inspire change through
action but you cannot do that until you
fill in all the different gaps of your
understanding about where we are how we
got here
and what we're supposed to do now and in
response to recent criticism in the
show's take on Hamilton race and slavery
Miranda tweeted that all the criticisms
are valid and that he struggled to
include all the complexities of the
characters in a two-and-a-half-hour
musical so what do you think of the
Hamilton musical and how it changed
history and were there any historical
inaccuracies which bothered you let me
know in the comments below
top left
to watch my next Hamilton video or tap
write for another video you're sure to
LIKE and if you enjoyed this I really
appreciate a thumbs up and a share
thanks for watching and see you next
time you pick a movie lovers